when I taught at the University of
Houston in the Creative Writing Program
we required the poets to take workshops
in in fiction writing and we required
the fiction writers to take workshops in
poetry and the reason for that is
because the fiction writers seemed to
need to learn how to pay greater
attention to language itself to the way
that laying which works the poets needed
to learn to pay greater attention to
character and to narrative that as many
poets don't know how to tell a story and
they don't have a sense of how to put
things in order to tell a story and we
thought that poets could learn from
fiction writers something about
developing a character over time who
wasn't just you and also creating a
narrative structure so I think it's true
that that's something that poetry can go
to school on fiction poetry and go to
fiction to learn think that the the the
deepest thing is that many fiction
writers tell stories but are not elegant
writers but we're not writing journalism
when we're making literature we are
trying to make something that lasts in
language and there's no question that
many fiction writers began as poets and
it's hard for me to think of any good
fiction writers who don't also read
poetry that fiction writers learn about
the development of metaphor the the use
of rhythm the way that language is
compacted in order to express that the
feelings that express their own feelings
of the feelings of their characters so I
think fiction goes to poetry for the
intensity of its use of language
when I was young I did and in fact when
I was young I wrote everything and I
thought I would be an all-round writer
that I would write everything when I was
in my early 20s I still had that idea
and I wrote an unpublished novel and I
wrote a lot of short stories but what I
described what I what I discovered about
myself is that my temperament is so
fiery in terms of what I like in
literature that I like so much intensity
that too much was happening all the time
it was it was just like starting with
too much adrenaline and you stated and
then adrenaline rush all the time it
turns out that doesn't work for fiction
fiction has to take a novel takes place
over time it's a historical narrative
and it needs to have a series of peaks
and valleys and to move through to no
you can't just start at the highest
pitch and stay there but you can Italy
in a lyric poem and so I found my
temperament is very much drawn to the
lyric poetry and for the compression of
lyric poetry so it seems that I have the
the temperament of a poet not entirely
of a fiction writer
there's a debate in the whole history of
poetry between the plane style and the
golden hour aureate style in the poetry
is continually in some kind of
relationship between these two pulls
something more Baroque in ornate
something more ornamental and something
more plain spoken something simpler and
I feel the tugs of those two traditions
in say the 17th century or in Spanish
baroque poetry or the work of John Donne
who I admire very much and so what I
would say is I myself have a especially
as I've gotten older I longed for
clarity and I longed for the the pure
clear word but by the drive but by the
drive of the feeling and the intensity
of the expression and the thing you're
trying to express and make you hope that
the words have wings that is you're
looking for something that will lift
them off now how to get that lift off no
one knows exactly and there's no recipe
for it
if there was everyone to be writing
great poems ever want to be going to
school with Emily Dickinson writing
those you know remarkable lyrics of hers
or writing Shakespeare sonnets but what
you're looking for is a kind of clear
language that gets a kind that gets a
depth charge that lifts it and gives it
wings so you hear the phrase brightness
falls from the air and you know you're
in the presence of poetry that something
has happened to the language the words
themselves brightness falls from the air
are all very clear and very simple but
when they come together in this
particular way they've got a radiance
and a beauty that stands all alone and I
think that what is that the observation
of light the
garetty of the feeling the sense of
wonder the words give you no one knows
exactly but you're seeking in this
combination of words to find something
new and fresh that will strike a deeply
resonant chord so that when we read
Sappho now it's as powerful to us as
when it was written in lesbos so many
centuries ago